Speaker 1: During yesterday's pathetic campaign
launch rally for Nikki Haley's 2024 Republican
primary run. She did say one thing that's really
funny, which is she demanded a cognitive test for
any candidate that's over 75 years old. It just so
happens that Donald Trump is 76 years old now. I,
I think she's only talking about this
overtly when it comes to Joe Biden.
But it's a pretty interesting way to also
draw distinction with the guy she's running
against in the primary. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: We'll have term limits for Congress.
And mandatory mental competency
tests for politicians over 70.
Speaker 1: Five years on. Now, I love this because
obviously the big meaning of it is Joe Biden is 80
and the right loves to talk about that. And one of
the main arguments that Nikki Haley is making in
this just nascent primary campaign is that she's
younger, that she is from a different generation.
But we all, of course, know that Trump's brain has
glitched very badly over the last six years. And
there are real questions about Trump and cognitive
tests as well. And Trump would also be subject to
one. So I believe that although the. Of official
meaning of this cognitive tests thing is a signal
about Biden. You all know that Nikki Haley
is also using it to talk about Trump. I don't
know whether the people in her audience realize
that, which makes it particularly funny. Now,
the fact remains that she can talk about cognitive
tests all she wants and whether 80 year old Biden
or 76 year old Trump, who would be 82 and 78 at
the time of the next inauguration, I think roughly
she can talk about that all she wants. She still
drawn absolutely no policy distinction from Donald
Trump. And in order to face Joe Biden, she
first needs to win the Republican primary.
And at this point in time, it's not clear what her
argument is for why anybody should vote for her,
other than I'm younger than Trump. Maybe that
resonates with the Republican Party at this point.
I don't know. It's going to be a real question.
My guess is that by Monday, maybe by Tuesday, we
will have some polling in the Republican primary.
That is from after Nikki Haley's announcement.
She went in polling 3% as a non-candidate.
We'll see where she ends up Monday, Tuesday.